hello and welcome to this video a la
deal already know so I've came in ice
king's indian something easy Mia maybe
maybe why is he going before somewhat
strange line and that you five is
supposed to be more aggressive but this
is not bad it's a French reversed but
there are some twists and this is one of
them I recently looked at a game where
this opening was featured and i found
this idea to be particularly interesting
it's not not so easy for black now to
keep the ball if you don't have Bishop
f5 okay so immediately sacrifices the
pawn basically yeah but I'm winning the
pond now here right why not I think I do
what just one day and I can then it just
take it I have 95 s williams upset sir
also in this night has no squares if i
would have played h3 when the remember
would what was the destination of that
night hmm integral f 3 it's the same
issue i also have night this side but
the blunders before so let's not do that
on a strange position exactly played age
31 de have won the 90s newest class bed
I think I could have done that now my
actual threat was 95 which he prevented
and came if I play age three and attack
it again technol squares him what is
weird position and we had gained him but
there is no square that is simply is no
square
no night as a gunner you yeah Bishop f4
looks pretty strong it isn't written all
that much in yes till t5 is not a threat
so I can complete my development team d
5 I take once and then probably oak see
one yeah I was thinking just castling
long here but Jesus is also good here
let's just stop d65 forever it also
makes the night look at it weird on this
seven yeah this is this is a good move I
mean why does the full piece up so you
mostly have to make sure that there's
not some swindle happening because the
king is a bit open
yeah so where do I put it the king could
castle long walking ever to i think i
think i got long carefully but what
looked really safe to be honest now
Knight f6 of any night move was the idea
here I can take the six can I not it
doesn't look it looks like there's a
problem with that
now now 925 comes up night before no no
don't want that to happen I mean
probably not so dangerous but there's
really no need to rush here
and probably this just trade this off
okay just be six or so I mean okay thats
thats hanging with
check late okay yeah but that he
basically stumbled into someone opening
some openings land mine this is
something that I recently looked at so
it was a bit bit unlucky friend to step
into it yeah this this and now this is
interesting a Bishop g7 it is a game
that I recently looked at where h5 was
played and I want that ok why would like
try h5 and I figured that this could be
really a problem look like at least it
is difficult to play the engine here
suggests h6 which is probably right yeah
stop the porn from the time being and I
need like if I go h4 I'm not threatening
g5 because each one is hanging so this
is some look like I can do this and play
group g1 try to play g5 next but it
stops me for one moment and this was
basically and I think that basically
loses 95 mm I'm silly I could just do
this and win the peace immediately but
that was it was just just just not not
well thought out of course this is also
very good for white with a tree it's a
piece you have this one still winning
the peace there's nothing to do them
yeah you just need to not bland and
stuff which I for once managed to do and
so this is interesting this opening
itself here it is a quite tricky opening
for for both sides actually an
interesting thing is that here if we
include see to death knight c6 if i'm
not mistaken there's some really weird
complication sometimes
so when he has a smaller better about to
play against us this rare line ok guys
thanks for watching